now it does keep going
um i won't i won't dwell on this too
much unless you ask me a question in
question time
but um the preliminary course which is
sort of like your warm-up for the hsc
it lasts three times in year 11. okay
and then
in term four of next year you start the
hsc course it lasts 12 months
and if you do general maths it breaks
off into two branches
this is actually quite new this is only
in the last few years they're called
general one in general too
as you can see the main difference
between them is that general one has no
assessments
you're like sweet that's great i'll do
that
you can but you can't get an atar at the
end okay it's not atar eligible
right so general two is what traditional
general math is about
alternatively if you decide no no i've
i've answered yes i want to have a go at
this big hairy
mathematical topic called calculus
you'll do
either mathematics two unit
or mathematics and math extension one
three unit you'll do that
in year 11 and then you get another
choice you need 12.
um this is for universe 4 in demands
okay
it only exists in the hsc course much
like for your english actually which i
also study
so you get this choice in term four of
year 11.
obviously the criteria that i mentioned
before
right apply from three to four units but
even more so
okay um the topics that are under this
complex numbers
conics polynomials they're really things
that twist your mind and you can't just
picture something there and like oh it's
really obvious they're very very
abstract problems
okay so those are the choices you'll get
to face
this is kind of a bird's-eye view of the
whole thing right now remember i said to
you before it'll be really useful if you
can find out if you're a
five one-ish or five two-ish or
five-three-ish class
okay try and find out that information
because it's not it doesn't lock you in
but it does give you a broad idea of
where you might head in the future
ability-wise so it's trying to answer
this question for you okay
you can see that you've got these little
streams here which tell you there are
alternative ways to go through it
but by and large the only people who do
extension one are the five three people
and the really strong
five two people and that's why you've
got a broad arrow here and a thin arrow
here okay and then you can see how it
progresses into the same idea
all right